finalísima entre argentina e italia gran
partido del que tuvimos hoy argentina se
impuso a italia por goleada para
exhibirse como la primera campeona del
torneo una victoria conseguida con un
messi brillante y en medio de la
reapertura del eterno debate entra la
diferencia de nivel entre el fútbol de
sudamérica y el del 'viejo continente'
allí en londres estuvo presente nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz giraldo quien
nos envió previamente el siguiente
informe
argentina vuelve a ponerse la camiseta
de campeón prácticamente un año después
de haber ganado también a la copa
américa y de terminar con esos 28 años
sin títulos y lo hizo aquí en wembley
ante el campeón europeo italia en esto
que se llamó la finalísima con una
victoria de 3 goles por 0 para argentina
la idea de esta finalísima era sobre
todo la de ir poco a poco pues ya
encaminándose hacia qatar y de paso
llevarse el título si era posible
mientras que para italia era más una
necesidad de poder levantar este trofeo
después de no lograr su clasificación a
la mundial de fútbol a finales de este
año en estar el partido argentina salió
con todo a ganar salió con un fuego
bastante en vertical preciso pero
también a un muy bonito que luego pues
ya fue funcionando sobre el minuto 28
con un primer gol de lautaro martínez
por un pase como un guante de leo messi
luego el segundo gol que llegó en el
minuto 45 un golazo de ángel dimaría con
ese resultado se fueron al descanso en
el segundo tiempo leonel messi buscó por
todos los medios ese gol que siempre le
están esquivo con la selección argentina
no funcionó pero sí se llevó el título
del mejor jugador del partido con sus
gambetas con su creación de juego con
sus son magníficos oa pases sin embargo
el tercer gol de argentina llegaría no
gracias a messi pero sí a paulo dybala
quien justamente acababa de entrar sobre
el terreno de juego la italia que vimos
esta noche aquí es una italia
completamente desconocida desdibujada de
ese equipo tan bonito que logró roberto
mancini que se enamoró a todo el mundo
durante esa eurocopa del año pasado
ahora argentina en realidad con este
resultado de tres goles o por 0 se da
fuerzas y se da también muchas ganas de
creer en que puede llegar muy lejos en
el próximo mundial de qatar mientras que
para italia pues es el final de una
temporada difícil de una temporada
triste y que además en este partido pues
ya despidió a su capitán el mítico
giorgio chiellini